the announcement by german economy  minister robert harvey this morning to  trigger the so-called gas emergency plan  sent shockwaves to europe  [Music]  germany being the economic powerhouse of  europe is of course central to the  economic well-being of europe as a whole  [Music]  this is the first phase of this  emergency plan but the probability is  quite high that  phase two and three will follow soon  which would mean that german companies  would have would be cut off from gas  supplies  which would of course affect supply  lines in the whole of europe this will  have a huge effect on the european  economy  and  the next few days will show if  phase two of phase three will have to  follow